c'est peut-être l'image forte qui
restera de la visite des manuels macron
à beyrouth manches retroussées sueur au
front
le président français s'offre un bain de
foule à gué maillezais un quartier
dévasté de beyrouth à quelques
encablures du port des habitants
l'interpellent emmanuel macron va au
contact
un véritable spectacle pour les caméras
de télévision qui prend des airs d'
opération de communication pour le
président français en venant au liban 48
heures après les explosions qui ont
ravagé la ville emmanuel macron s'est
assigné une mission pour le moins
ambitieuse sur le plan matériel d'abord
il souhaite organiser l'aide
internationale et annonce la tenue
prochaine d'une conférence de soutien et
d'appui au liban paris a déjà envoyé
trois avions à beyrouth un quatrième
devrait arriver ce vendredi avec des
équipes de secours
sur le plan politique ensuite macron
appel à de vrais changements et à la
refondation du système
le ton est pour le moins offensif envers
les dirigeants du pays je ne suis pas là
pour cautionner quelques régimes aux
quelques politiques de ce soir j'ai
jusque là et c'est mon devoir
pour vous aider en tant que peuple pour
vous apporter les médicaments le soutien
de quoi vous nourrirez de quoi vous
aider à reconstruire
il sera transparent un érable sur le
terrain et fracas
pas dans les mains je vais aller parler
à toutes les forces politiques
je vais leur proposer un nouveau pacte
politique
cet après midi et je reviendrai pour le
1er septembre
et s'ils ne savent pas le tenir ce
paternalisme voir ingérence du président
les critiques de l'opposition française
n'ont pas tardé à se multiplier sur les
réseaux sociaux
d'où vient à maquereau sentiment de
toute puissance
quel est ce ton de quoi menace-t-il dans
quelle aventure mène-t-il la france
la libé de sarkozy n'a t'elle pas suffi
très indécent de venir jouer le porte
parole du fmi au liban quelques heures
seulement après la terrible explosion et
la tragédie humaine du côté du
gouvernement libanais l'entousiasme du
président français semble avoir suscité
des réactions mitigées
l'accueil est plutôt positif dans un
premier temps le président michel aoun
reçoit son homologue à l'aéroport dans
l'après midi la présidence libanaise
salue sa visite sur twitter le président
aoun a qualifié la visite du président
macron de réussie est bénéfique
soulignant que la france aiderait le
liban en revanche emmanuel macron et
seul lorsqu'il donne une conférence de
presse en fin de journée les us et
coutumes des rencontres présidentielle
aurait normalement impliquer la présence
de michel aoun ou côté de son invité
c'est le temps des responsabilités pour
le liban aujourd'hui et ses dirigeants
il faut rebâtir la confiance et l'espoir
elle ne se décrète pas elle ne se
reconquérir pas du jour au lendemain
en attendant la conférence
internationale de soutien et d'appui au
liban qui sera organisée prochainement
l'urgence est avant tout humanitaire
dans les rues de la capitale libanaise
une réalité qui n'a pas échappé à
emmanuel macron